pour finir car je ne peux conclure tant
il y aurait encore à dire oui j'en veux
bien évidemment à ceux qui croyent
accomplir un travail alors qu'ils
avaient un métier laissant de côté leur
savoir-faire préfant un savoir se taire
et au besoin un savoir faire taire la
dessence e été de le reconnaître et de
faire Amand d'honorable c'est la base du
savoir être dans ce monde on est plus on
a suber le paraître à l'être oui j'en
veux également à ceux qui choisissent
une vérité alternative défendu par
quelques courtisans cherchant carrière
cette vérité erronée et rassurante pour
eux et les maintient dans l'entre soi on
néprouve jamais de la honte face à
soi-même lorsque certains craignent le
regard des autres le jugement c'est bien
que celui-ci les renvoie à leur propre
culpabilité dans ce monde on détourne le
regard de l'autre ou bien on ferme
carrément les yeux oui j'en veux à ces
éternels adept de l'idéologie du P
vaguisme ceux qui sont les premiers à se
mettre à genoux et à regarder tomber
ceux qui sont restés debout bout se
murmura à l'oreille ah tu vois on a bien
fait de se coucher dans cette partie
géante de 1 de TR soleil le maître M et
ta bougée tu dégages cette pathologie
paralysante et tétanisante semble avoir
atteint par contagion l'état tout entier
la culture de PV sur l' libie à la
soumission terme injurieux mais surtout
inavoable pour être capable et coupable
du pire il faut bien se trouver des
raisons dans ce monde on valorise le
sujet obéissant passif parfois lâche et
on dénigre en qualifiant de traître le
sujet rebelle qui pourtant a agi comme
il convient au sens de la morale au sein
d'une société fortement hiérarchisée
agir comme il convient c'est d'abord au
contraire faire ce que l'autorité exige
de sorte que quiconque s'oppose à elle
s'expose à la réprobation générale loin
d'être considéré comme un héros que
pourtant Monsieur le Président Macron a
pu le dire le 21 octobre 2020 lors de
l'hommage national tenu à la Sorbonne le
sujet résistant est traité comme un
paria tenu à l'isolement et les à la
vindicte populaire ce qui conduira mon
frère à être livré seul en pature à la
mouvance islamiste mon frère a été
reconnu par certains et à tort coupable
de déloyauté le cûp de sa désobéissance
sera qu'il finira seul et que l'État
n'nera pas sa part du contrat social en
lui assurant protection le dernier
condamné à mort pour blasphème en France
n'est plus François Jean Le fèf de la
barre exécuté en 1766 à abeville c'est
désormais Samuel paatti exécuté en 2020
à Conflant
saint-honorine combien de temps vous
faudra-t-il pour comprendre que la
culture de la libi soit religieuse soit
ethnique est utilisé pour commettre les
pires exactions finalement à vouloir
éviter discrimination et stigmatisation
cette attitude amalgame est réduit au
silence ceux qui pensent comme mon frère
que je cite la vie de l'homme est le
droit le plus sacré qu il pris après ça
si je vous dis rien c'est désespérant
mais c'est la réalité est-ce qu'il y a
que l'horreur de ce vendredi 13 octobre
qui va me donner raison